hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today and in today's video we're
gonna be talking about the new voice
lines about how they're going to be
delayed and stuff like that and then the
Dubs thoughts on that and as well a few
other things talked about in the most
recent dead stream so let's get started
with that
so first up is there's going to be a
sale unning on the emo and that's going
to be the coin toss emote if you happen
to not have the coin toss emo for any of
the heroes that in for owner that you
wanted to get for it before it is not
discounted until September 27th which I
believe is a week from today so you have
all of this week to get it it's now
gonna be costing four thousand steel
instead of seven thousand so I
definitely want to grab that if you do
enjoy that email for the character you
want the event game mode for this is
going to be called carousel of death and
if you have not noticed what carousel
death is it's very similar to dance of
death dance of F is - V - where you
basically have to kill the opposing team
at the same exact time roughly within a
given window so that the ad the game
ends it's not just one person dies and
then the game is over they respawn until
both teammates are done carousel of
death is very similar to that except
it's a 4v4 game so a lot of hectic stuff
cannot wait to apply this one this drops
which I believe it is out today so I'm
glad I'm definitely to be hopping on
after this video and playing some of
that and there's also an event order
that goes with this called the special
slayer challenge be the faction with the
most takedowns performed at carousel def
that's only going to be going on for the
weekend so try to be the bigot the best
faction with that and you'll most likely
be getting some steel and some scavenger
crates as a reward another thing you
actually care about is the responsive
dialogue system aka the for honor voice
lines and in response to that basically
after hearing and reading a lot of the
player feedback regarding the system the
devs have decided to postpone it and
give it some time to basically give it
its full potential
the devs understand why most of the
voice lines we dislike and like I said
they've decided to postpone them for now
this doesn't mean that it won't be
available on the day that marching fire
releases it could be it could not be we
don't know yet there will be some future
updates later and closer to marching
fire in October so I'll definitely keep
you guys up to date on that on top of
that there's also a steel sale that's
30% of all steel packs for the weekend
so if you do want to buy some steel you
can do that they're all gonna be
discounted and apparently the devs
hinted at some stuff coming out next
week stream showing a lot of stuff
regarding marching fire I'm fairly
certain we knew everything about
marching fire but if there is more
things that we don't know about that
they're gonna show I'm always down for
new info so definitely recap for that
you--for you guys next week so stay
tuned for that
and the most important thing of this
whole video the content of the week
which is everyone's favorite thing
battle outfits there I don't know what
the prices is normal battle outfit stuff
I don't even look at the names it's how
much I don't care about this but yeah
the battle outfits are there you can
play the video in the background if you
guys do want to buy those they seem okay
but like I said they're usually battle
outfits so they're not really too great
but if you do want to buy that you can
see let me know what you guys think
about this stuff in the comments below
do you guys think it was right for the
devs to basically postpone the dialogue
system and we rework it a bit or
basically just let it how it was before
and it was better you know when they
first released it in the test or
anything like that I left in her
thoughts in the comments below
hey guys gonna be into the videos today
hopefully you guys did enjoy it but like
the V if he did subscribe for new I
cover the informational side I'll fall
on earth at being bells changes hero
updates patch notes leaks all that good
stuff as well some gladiator gameplay as
well my two most recent videos will be
on screen if you guys do want to check
that out one of them is the most spammed
moves of every character Kalon or so a
lot of people can according to the
comments related to these so if you
haven't seen that you can definitely
check that out that we awesome oh yeah
guys my two most recent videos would be
on screen if you guys do want to check
that out when that guys hope ever here
is today thank you for watching the
video and peace out
[Music]
you